I'm just stubborn man I just never give
up you're crazy until you're successful
then you're a genius get alive be
realistic people will convince you
you're out of your mind for wanting to
to do this then once you're successful
they're like yo your drive your tenacity
was great but it's like yeah well where
was that back then I knew deep down that
I could do something I was I was
different from other people I had
different experiences there was
something I needed to express there was
a purpose to the how my life had
unfolded but I couldn't find it if you
look at the Great ones they have one
thing in common they suffered more than
most people greatness really flows from
our disconnection to who we are intake
the outtake of what you call life is
nothing more than time and unless done
something with is forgotten about